‏z
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان
لا
اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول الله
حي على
الصلا حي على
الفلا حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله الا الله
الحمد لله ثم الحمد
لله نحمده ونشكره ونستغفره ونستعين به
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا دي الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك له
له الحمد يحيي ويميت وهو على كل شيء قدير
واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين وعلى من تبعهم باحسان
الى يوم الدين اما بعد قال الله تعالى في
كتابه المبين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا
تموتن انتم
مسلمون صدق الله
العظيم اللهع
[Silence]
تالى الله
تعالى in the semester school year for
those so scho the end is but not there
yet so keep on بتق
الله الله تالى قران بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم ونزلنا عليك الكتاب تبيانا لكل شيء
وهدى ورحمه وبشرى
للمسلمين صدق الله
العظيم قران
الله الله
‏a clarification
clarification guidance and
mercy
الله comm
‏more provides
ins الله تعالى
‏merc difficult situation what
happ help us down help get back together
right so this is pleas excuse me so it's
a mercy it's guidance and
also
tidings great in qu
[Silence]
‏life الله الرحمن
الرحيم الذي خلقكم من ضعف ثم من ب ضعف قوه
ثم جعل من ب قوه ضعفا وشيبا يخلق ما
يشاء وهو العليم القدير صدق الله العظيم
[Silence]
الله
تع allowing
all سحان الله there a cycle to life
we wec needy
‏strong
ىالى stronger and stronger
the and we going get we again perhaps we
are in the process of getting we again
[Silence]
‏kind think one teach frequently
mentioned there and in many places
people just ar kind to their parents
they don't talk to them they ignore them
you hear stories people visiting 10 from
where parents don't even st by say hello
salam سحان
الله
speci 2د
[Silence]
تعالى بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وصينا بوالديه
احسان حملته امه كره ووضعته كره
وحمله
شهرا حتى اذا
ا وبلغ اربعين
سنه الله
تعالى
الاقا الله تالى
[Silence]
‏his bearing and weing are 30 months so
this is again a description right from
ancient times until
today pregnancy has lasted a certain
amount time and then weing has also
lasted
time is on challeng on another be ex
kind to to ours
[Silence]
سنه تعالى قال ربي اوزعني اشكر نعمك التي
انعمت عل وعلى والدي وان
ترضاه واصلح لي في ذريتي اني تبت اليك
واني من المسلمين صدق الله العظيم
[Silence]
‏upon my the you bested upon me and upon
my parents and that i may virtue
pleasing to سحان
الله0 اللهى
‏also with a l of support from our
parents and the blessings that they have
received as well so we start thanking
الله تعالى for the b الله تالى upon us
and then we thank الله تالى for those
upon our parents and then we ask we act
kindly virtuous in a man ising
to but it doesn't end there it continues
the continues to say ‏grant me a
virtuous or a righteous pry grant me
righteous children descends verily i
have repented or turned to you and
verily i am among the muslims the people
who submit to
you here perh because for those of us
who
children there's a good chance by the
time one is 40 one has had some children
and if not one is maybe thinking about
that
‏ask all things
short us
how how
easy are we grun 10
days may not butful
الله we
men and there are two situations into
which children come into this world
either their parents are married they
are not married and in the united states
right now a little
frightening in entire united states
[Silence]
‏enour
teached
butes enour mar i particular i was
thinking
نالى الله الرحمن الي
الايام منكم والصالحين من عبادكم
واكم يكون فقراء يخم الله فضله والله واسع
عليم
صدق ‏mar unwed among you and the
virtuous among your slaves male and
female and if they are if they are needy
en them from his b سحان الله what اللهى
enrich them from b الله alling in all
knowing so this is a beauful indic
reminder we help people who are seeking
spouses to make it easier for them bless
those who are in a state of matrimony
‏in there another
beau
ind
and i willing
ايه النور بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم بيوت
الله ترفع ويذكر اسمه يسبح له
في
والاصال رجال لا تليهم تجاره ولا بيع عن
ذكر
الله واقام الصلاه
وايتاء زكاه
يفون
يما
فيلوب
والابصار صدق الله
العظ الله تعالى
[Silence]
‏trade distracts from the of allah
holding pray and
giving hearts and eyes turn again سبحان
الله اللهى
does الله تالى الله
تالى remember
الله uphold our prayers uphold our
charity which usually requires a job to
have
‏is to get bog down by
work by extra assigns we might take on
and to be distracted from the remem of
allah and so
us out make
lived but
‏noted let dist us
from on time and being gener
with ask make among those who are not
distracted by our work from remembering
him who make it easier for us to pray
our prayers on
time for us to give up our income and
don generous
اقول قولي هذا واستغفر الله لي ولكم
استغفر الله ان الله غفور الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله ثم الحمد لله اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم على سدنا محمد
وه وصحبه اجمعين من تبعهم باحسان يوم
الدين الحد
[Silence]
خيالى ونلنا عليك الكتاب تبيانا
لكل
وش صدق الله العظم تعالى
مح صل الله عليه
وسلم
بكران
الكب which clarifies which there is
cation for
all guid there mercy and there
[Silence]
‏te تالى الله الرحمن اليم
عن
الله الله
تعالى الله
تعالى
ولنجزين الذين صبروا اجرهم باحسن ما كانوا
يعملون تعالى
‏so
it's things might seem they to be
the same forever things might seem like
going to forever everything
perishes and
that we spoke
inle there
الله تعالى بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم ان الله عنده علم الساعه وينزل
الخير يعلم
الار وما تدري نفس ماذا تكسب غدا وما تدري
نفس باي ارض تموت ان الله عليم خبير صصدق
الله العظيم
الله
inn allowing
مح
الخ صلى الله عليه وسلم حديث صح
البخاري صلى الله عليه
وسلم مفتاح الخيب خمس لا يعلمها الا الله
لا ي احد ما يكون في ولا يعل ما يكون في
الارحام ولا تعلم نفس ماذا تسب
وما تدري نفس باي ارض تموت وما يدري احدت
يجيء
المطر صل الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
keenen how
قررنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنهن
علينا صبرا وث اقدا وانصرنا على القوم
الكافرين ربنا لا تؤخذنا ان نسينا واخط
ربنا ولا تحمل علينا
اسرا الذين من قبلنا ربنا ولا تحملنا ملا
طاقه لنا به واعف عنا واغفر لنا
وارحمنا كافرين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما
يصفون والسلام على المرسلين الحمد لله رب
العالمين عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعد
والحسان وايتاء ذ القربا وينهانا الفحشاء
والمنكر والخي يعذ لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا
الله
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا الله اشهد
ان لا اله الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلا حي على الصلا حي على الفلا حي على
الفلا قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله
اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نين احدنا السراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عل غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين ولله ما في السماوات وما في الارض
ليجزي الذين
اساءوا بما عملوا ويجزي الذين احسنوا
بالحسنى الذين يجتنبون كباء ال الاثم
والفواحش الا اللمم ان ربك واسع المغفره
هو اعلم بكم
اذام من الارض اذ انتم جنه في بطون
امهاتكم فلا
تزكوا
انفسكم هو اعلم بمن
اتقى افريت الذي تولى واعطى قليلا
واكدى ا عنده علم الغيب فو يرى ام لم ينبى
بما في صحف موسى وابرا يم
الذيف الا تزر وازره وزر اخرى وان ليس
للانسان الا ما سعى وان سعيه سوف يرى ثم
يجزاه الجزاء الاوفى وان الى ربك
المنت الله
سميع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك ن
نستعين اهدنا صراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
ضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والعاديات طحا ف موريات قدحا ف
مخرات الصبحا فاثرن به نقعا فوسطن به
جمعا ان الانسان لربه لكنود وانه على ذلك
لشهيد وانه لحب الخير ل الشديد افلا يعلم
اذا بعثر ما في
القبور وحصل ما في
الصدور ان ربهم بهم يومئذ لخبير
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم الله
وبركاته السلام علكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته ان شا الله first
‏shaking grateful for for having i don't
think you guys understand in all
seriousness what great person we have
here cali the person is to be present
and he nice for
me be thankful
scu قران حث رول الله صل عليه
وسم انء
الله
الله for the sisters upstairs if you
look at donation boxes there is actually
ta and a wireless
keypad pin next to it you can dons
whatever contribution you contribute
that the and cay apple pay gole
payung payou
‏for
yous sy downstairs there cr two
systemair
place
tr for sistern
[Silence]
80 into it scho will start back up this
if you have children who want to be
register be here 10:30 and take care of
every sle at the
[Silence]
‏sch
‏present
some things
all جزاك الله خير